ولدينا المزيد من مقاطع الفيديو الجديدة التي
تظهر المذبحة بعد أن
صنف مسلحو حماس مهرجانًا موسيقيًا سلميًا
في جنوب إسرائيل بالقرب من غزة.
أريد أن أحذر مشاهدينا من أنك قد
تجد هذا الأمر مزعجًا عندما ترى شاحنة مليئة
بثقوب الرصاص
والجثث.  شخصين ميتين يبدوان
ميتين على الأرض بعد إطلاق النار عليهما
بدم بارد بينما كانا
يركضان كما أفاد أولئك الذين كانوا
هناك في الساعة 6:30 صباحًا سمعوا
القصف ثم فجأة تعرضوا
لهجوم من قبل مسلحين من مسلحي غزة
وماذا  أنتم تنظرون هنا إلى
رجل وامرأة يتم أخذهما كرهائن من قبل
مسلحي غازين مكانهما غير معروف ولكن
عائلة أه هؤلاء الأشخاص قالوا
إنهم يريدون سي إن إن أه أن تعرض هذه
الصور على الرغم من أنها مزعجة
لأنهم يأملون أن تساعد أه
أخرجوا هذه المرأة والرجل
من أه خارج غزة حيث
يبدو أنهما محتجزان في
الوقت الحالي